you mentioned karl marx
as um
one of the great intellects
economic
thinkers ever yeah he's not he might be
number one you study him quite a bit you
disagree with him quite a bit yeah but
you still think
he's a powerful
powerful mind yeah a powerful mind so
first of all let's let's just explore
the human um
uh
why do you say so what's interesting in
that mind in the way he saw the world
what are the insights
that you find brilliant the marx once
described his major workers towards a
critical uh
examination of everything existing
so he's a modest bastard yeah so he he
wanted to understand and criticize
everything yeah and
uh even he he wasn't trained directly by
hegel but he was his teachers were
hegelian philosophers and what
hegel developed was a concept called
dialectics
and dialectics is a philosophy of change
and
when most people
hear the word dialectics they come up
with this unpronounceable trio of words
called thesis
antithesis synthesis i can barely get
the words out myself yeah and that
actually is not hegel at all that's
another german philosopher
oh fiction i thought it was kind no
effect well i'm not sure you could i mix
them up all germans like you've seen to
me yeah there we go
um
so but if you look this beautiful book
called marks and contradiction you want
to find a great explanation for marx's
philosophy i've forgotten the author i
think it's wild w i lda marx and
contradiction and he points out the
actual origins of marx's philosophy i
didn't know that when i first read mark
so i became exposed to marx
when i was a student at sydney
university and we'd had a strike
at the university over the teaching of
philosophy
and
what happened was the philosophy
department had a lot of radical
philosophers in it and a conservative
chief philosopher
and
the the radicals wanted to have a course
on what they called feminist aspects of
philosophical sorry philosophical
aspects of feminist thought
and the staff voted in favor of it this
is back in the days when university
departments were democratic the
professor opposed it he got it blocked
at a high level the staff left frogged
over that and then finally the vice
chancellor blocked it so that led to a
strike
over the teaching of philosophy at
sydney university which at one stage
over pretty over half the students were
on strike okay
economics began out of that teaching of
a philosophy of feminism yes
that it's good to be that's such a
different life to what we're living now
but that's the
academic milieu in which i
developed all my ideas and and i had
become a critic i've gone from being a
believer of mainstream economics when i
was a first year student
to disbelieving it halfway through first
year okay and i then spent a long time
trying to change it and getting nowhere
and then this philosophy strike happened
and we took it on in economics and we
formed what's called the political
political economy movement and had a
successful strike we actually uh managed
to pressure the
university into establishing a
department of political economy at
sydney university as well as the
department of economics what was the
foundational ideas
were you resistant to the whole
censorship of
why aren't we having why can't you have
a philosophy of anything kind of course
well it was with much more
libertarian in the genuine sense of the
word period of time
at the end of the beginning of the 60s
beginning of the 70s than the word
libertarian has been corrupted since
then but it really was about free
thought and you went to university to
learn it was about education i remember
having a fight with my father once where
dad was angry about the marks i was
getting some of my courses and he said
if you don't get a decent result you
won't get a a decent job and i said i'm
not here to get a job i'm here to get an
education
oh wow okay now the thing is ultimately
it's been a pretty good job for me as
well this is in sydney by the way and
sydney in summer is absolutely gorgeous
and what does us bunch of lefties decide
to do during summer but read karl marx
yeah on the beach or uh actually inside
the uh
of the room of the philosophy department
at the university of sydney in the main
quadrangle there's sandstone all around
us and we've a bunch of about 20 or 30
of us reading our way through marks
capital
and
i remember walking off to that meeting
with one of my friends uh who's the law
student and we this was a period of a
huge
construction boom in sydney so the whole
skyline which we could see from the
campus was full of what they call
kangaroo cranes which were an australian
invention that are cranes that can be
leapfrogged over each other to build a
skyscraper so here you are reading karl
marx looking at the at the mechanisms of
capitalism i looked at those mechanisms
and i knew marx argued that labor was
the only source of value yeah and he
said machinery doesn't add value so the
cranes
are worthless i'm looking at these
cranes i'm thinking i want a very good
explanation by marks as to why these
cranes don't add value so reading
through the first seven chapters of
capital what you found was marks
applying this dialectic and like the 50
and stuff is [ __ ] that is not how
marx thought at all i was reading trying
to find this thesis antithesis synthesis
and it's not there at all in any of
marx's works and i've read everything
he's ever written
on economics from 1844 to 1894 when he
was
his last books were published there's
not one word of mention of that what he
does talk about is foreground and
background intention
and his idea of a dialectic is that
there is
a unity
will exist in society and that unity can
be individual there can be a commodity
anything at all
the the unity will be understood by that
society
one particular aspect will be focused
upon so if you think about
the human being in capitalism the focus
on the human being as an object is their
capacity to work
you're a worker okay that's put in the
foreground
the fact that you're human and you want
to play a guitar and go surfing and make
love and all the other things that
humans do is pushed into the background
there's a tension between the two of
those
and that can transform that unity over
time and that's a beautiful dynamic
vision
of change so dialectics is a philosophy
of change so synthesis antithesis is uh
what does every idea have
a counter argument yeah there's a
positive and negative and you bring them
together somehow and then mark says this
foreground background foreground
is all what we think of as economics and
backgrounds all the lovemaking we do as
humans that sort of thing and and why is
what's why is there attention well
because you imagine if you imagine the
unity like if you take a human
you know any previous it could go back
to cro-magnon days when we're you know
living in caves and
we've got to go hunting and cook food
and stuff like that but there's no
social hierarchy as we've become used to
so you don't get labored as a worker or
a capitalist you're just a human in that
situation then you'll you've got more of
an integrated view of who you are and i
think that's one of the appeals of a
tribal a genuine tribal culture that you
get treated for the whole of who you are
you've certainly categorized you're male
you're female you're young you're old
you're a hunter you're a you're a tool
maker et cetera et cetera but you're
treated as more an integrated object
when you get put in a complex society
like a capitalist society then one side
of you is emphasized and the others are
de-emphasized so is it fair to say that
the background is like our basic
fundamental humanity
and the foreground is the machine of
capitalism effectively and when you look
at in terms of a human but what marx did
is apply this to a commodity
he said what is the essential unity in a
capitalist economy and the essential
unity is a commodity okay that's such a
the essential unit the essential unity
was the unit unity an object in society
okay okay so he started from the point
of view of trying to understand what how
exchange occurs
how do we set prices and his starting
vision was to say that a commodity is a
unity
in a capitalist economy
the part of the unity
that we focus upon is the its exchange
value
a capitalist produces a commodity not
because of its
qualitative characteristics but because
it be sold for a profit
so the foreground aspect of a commodity
is its exchange value
the background aspect of it it won't
succeed as a commodity unless it has a
use value
so the background is the utility thing
yeah see
if you made something which didn't work
okay yeah then it has you might be able
to sell it but it has no utility that
can't you can't make that into a
commodity a broken thing can't be sold
does that have the subjective yeah it
has to have the subjective side for
people as well as the objective so the
objective is what capitalists worry
about i'll give you my favorite counter
example of that i was in i took a bunch
of australian journalists to china way
back in the
period when the gang of four was was
being on trial and we did a tour of the
forbidden city in
beijing and at that stage all the
artifacts of the royal family the
emperor were actually in the building
still and we walked past one of them and
it was this
gold solid gold bar about this long
shaped like a fist turned over like this
and on this side
there were rubies emeralds diamonds
you'd never seen gemstones i mean gems
that big
and one of the journalists asked me what
i thought it was and i said oh it's
obvious jane is the back scratcher
i walked away she caught up with me
about 20 minutes later that i asked one
of the guys it is a backscratcher wow so
here's a back scratcher for the emperor
made of solid gold with diamonds and
rubies and emeralds during the
scratching yeah and that's that's a
commodity in a feudal society okay the
cost doesn't matter
you want the most elaborate beautiful
thing because you're the emperor
so you in that in a feudal society the
commodity what's focused upon is the
utility
and the cost of production when you when
you're the emperor is immaterial
capitalism reverses that
so the commodity in a capitalist economy
is the plastic two dollar scratcher you
can get from kmart
or target yeah and so the the use value
is
necessary but irrelevant to forming the
price
now that was a completely different
vision of exchanging capitalism to what
i found in the neoclassical theory
because that says it's the marginal
utility and the marginal cost of
everything that determines the exchange
ratio and the crazy thing about that is
not so much the
marginal utility but
the argument in in the neoclassical
theory is that the price ratio the price
will
when there's an exchange going on
there's two person two commodity
exchange of com of two commodities
between two people
uh
they will
show the the price will change until
such time as the ratio of the marginal
utilities is equal to the ratio of the
marginal costs
that's supposed to be the equilibrium
now mark says that's [ __ ] that's a
previous society where you exchange
stuff that you happen to have the stuff
somebody else happened to have
without any real production mechanism
being involved and he said that's like
when you when you have an eight two
ancient trial or two tribes meeting for
the very first time and one tribe can
make something the other tribe can't
make
and they will therefore
the price they were willing to pay
will reflect how unique this other
object is that the this one tribe can
make and the other can't so for example
the story of manhattan being sold for 40
glass beads
it's actually 40 glass trading booths i
believe it is a true story but the thing
is the indians couldn't make glass beads
so they value the glass beads of the
island of manhattan okay which is a
utility-based comparison what mark said
that's the very initial contact
over time even if you don't know the
technology over time you start to
realize how much work goes involved to
making what they're selling you versus
what you're selling to them
and you start making stuff specifically
for sale
so you know elon's not losing personal
utility each time a model 3 goes out the
door
there's no he might get utility out of
the fact that he's created that vehicle
that concept and manufactures it and so
on but he's not losing utility each time
a model t forward goes out the door for
going back for the ancient
ancient commodity there so
the utility plays no role in setting
price in marx's model
whereas it's essential in the
neoclassical model what's the difference
between utility and marginal utility
what does the word marginal mean
and why is this such a problem it turns
marginal utility well the utility itself
has different meanings in the two
schools of thought if you take the
classical school of thought which when
marx comes from utility is effectively
objective
so the utility of a chair is that you
can sit in it
okay not how comfortable it makes you
feel
yeah okay now if you think about the
utility of the chairs we're both sitting
and they're identical from a classical
point of view we're both sitting okay
but from the neoclassical point of view
it's how comfortable it makes you feel
and that depends upon your subjective
feelings of comfort you might be far
more comfortable in the identical chair
that i'm sitting in than i am yeah and
therefore the comparison is difficult
and therefore working out a ratio
involves you've got a decline in your
each time you give away a chair in
exchange for a
iphone you have a fall in your utility
okay but
and then therefore you want a higher
return because you're losing more
utility each time the the more chairs
you give away the less utility you're
getting from chairs so there's a decline
in your utility that's your your
marginal utility
so it's including your subjective
valuation in setting the price
and what mark's pointed out is this is a
caricature
of actual change in the capitalist
economy because we have in a capitalist
economy huge factories sending out huge
quantities specifically for sale they've
got no utility to the um seller unless
they're sold
okay so it's a it's a very different
vision of where how prices said and marx
used that to explain
where profit comes from but he made a
mistake
and his argument was that
talking about a worker uh
as now your unity this foreground
background tension thing the foreground
is that you hire a worker
for their cost of production and the
cost of production is a subsistence wage
okay
the utility to the buyer
is the fact that they can work
in a factory now it might take
six hours let's say to make the means of
subsistence and that's the exchange
value and that's what the capitalist
pays as a wage to the worker but they
can work in the factory for 12 hours
that's the utility
twelve minus six is six
surplus of value hours and that's where
profit comes from
and that was marx's argument and i
thought it was brilliant
but it also applied to machinery
right okay let's let's let's
say no no deep deep is good you just
want to define
uh terms don't take that statement out
of context the internet please
okay uh
you said buyer
seller
worker
in a factory who's the seller who's the
buyer well you know
why is the worker
the buyer well the work is the commodity
in this case because when if you're
going to make stuff in a factory you've
got to hire workers yes okay and what
marx is saying the buyer in that
situation is a capitalist so what does
the buyer pay he says he pays the
exchange value that's they get back to
the commodity thing that this is because
that's the starting point he said the
essential unity in a capitalist economy
is the commodity
a commodity has two characteristics
exchange value and use value okay
exchange value of a commodity in a
capitalist economy will be its cost of
production
the use value
is what you do with it okay once you've
purchased it but labor is
a commodity in this case when you're
when a worker is being hired for a job
yes so the workers
labor
has an exchange value and a use value as
well yeah youth value use value of a
worker's labor exchange value
let me think about that so that
so the hours they put in
here's the use value
interesting so what uh
what does the worker
want in this
what are the motivations are we not
considering the worker in this context
as a human being
that's actually that's that's the next
layer what what mark's good was just
like a a layered cake
starting from the foundation of saying
straight commodity exchange and then
saying well you're treating a workers a
commodity now a commodity is something
you know like this
okay that has so far as i'm aware no
soul okay yeah not going to be
complaining if i turn it upside down
it'll fall over but yeah
so that's there's no soul there as a
human
is both a commodity and a non-commodity
yeah and therefore there'll be a tension
in the person i'm being treated as a
commodity here i'm being paid just
enough to stay alive
you know i've got a wife and kids back
at home yeah
so that that is another layer of
thinking in marks and on that lady then
says well workers will therefore demand
more than their value so that's when you
get like political you get political and
you get money coming above that and so
on but the basic idea starts from the
commodities the fundamental unity and
capitalism
the important commodity in marx's
thinking was the worker because that's
where he said profit came from yeah okay
and then that explains the motivation of
the capitalist and that ultimately sort
of labor theory of value and
marx's arguments about how capitalism
will come to an end
you